[Music]
Hey welcome to another episode of black
man beyond my name is mark barnard I am
here as you can see not in the cantina I
am in my fortress of solitude EEG my car
because I'm not going to do an episode
of black man beyond here from my car
though that would be kind of fun but
hard to sell tickets to this is an
introduction to what you're about to
hear which is a conversation with Damon
Lindelof about Watchmen I was invited
three weeks ago by the Writers Guild of
America to moderate a conversation with
Damon about his show about the show that
he produced and ran with about 14 other
people many of which he gives credit to
in this conversation but so yeah that's
what happened last night actually
December 12th I went to the writers
guild and talked to Damon for about an
hour about lots of things Watchmen chief
among them a little bit of Nash Bridges
a little bit of Mad Max fury road a
little bit of into the spider-verse
of all things but yes I've talked to him
about an hour and 15 Q&A with a crowd
for another half hour and Damon was
incredibly candid and forthcoming about
lots of different things I think you'll
enjoy this conversation if you don't
it's not because we didn't try to give
you this and you know in case you're
still listening to this feed waiting for
Kevin to show back up again you will get
him we have two shows coming up we're
doing a live fat man Beyond on the
forecourt of the Chinese Theater on
Hollywood Boulevard on Saturday the 14th
and we are doing a live fat man beyond
in the cantina me and Kevin Smith on
Tuesday the 17th and that will be our
last show of the year unless Kevin has a
change of heart which without knows he
might he might not but this is what I'm
planning so I'll probably have my top 10
of the year by then with a couple of
gaping holes don't know if he will Kevin
and I will get to talk about Watchmen
for the first time so uh so yes tickets
are on sale go to see Smaug calm to get
those those those sweet passes to
paradise if not I will see you here on
the interwebs I hope you guys are doing
well and you know same black times same
blog channel see you guys soon I
[Applause]
hello everybody how are you how are you
yeah no you how are you no you yeah
let's go awesome well thank you for
coming everybody
my name is Mark Barnard enlike like the
nice lady said but you're not here to
see me because I understand this because
I'm relatively self-aware but instead
we're going to talk to a man who has
delivered unto us a show about class
about race about crime about justice
about the the tenuous connections
between people through time and space
well [ __ ] clap your hands for the
story editor of Nash Bridges Damon
Lindelof
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I'm very very proud of national yeah
listen before we get into Watchmen I
have a frill nash bridges question cute
well I have to the first of which is how
familiar with you were you with Don
Johnson clearly some and the story of
eight billion dollars worth of bearer
bonds in his trunk so the story to which
you refer is it this happened while I
was working on Nash Bridges there were
two scandals that encircled Don Johnson
while I was recognized
- Bridget which was the final season of
Nash Bridges the first was that he was I
photographed coming out of some sex
store with a huge paper bag with like
dildos and was like in the front page of
The Enquirer and then the second was
that I believe is in Germany he was
attempting to cross the border and they
searched his vehicle and he had 8
billion with the B dollars worth of
bearer bonds which the only other time
that I've heard that phrase was in the
movie die hard and with like and and his
response is sort of like how did that
get in yeah called Treadstone which if
you haven't seen that's fine but uh
because it's whatever but it's part of
the plot is people are trying to
purchase a nuclear missile and we had no
idea how much a nuclear missile cost
that's probably a good thing yeah and so
we all said ok here's the thing if Don
Johnson of a billion dollars in his
trunk it should be more than more than
that more than yeah my other knife Nash
Bridges question is aside from meeting
Carlton Cuse what did you take away from
that show well that that was my first I
my my first writing job my first paid
writing job was on the show called
wasteland which was the year before Nash
Bridges that's a story for another time
this time but but wasteland sort of
lived and died very quickly and so Nash
Bridges I came on and it was in its
sixth season which was its last season
but it was an incredibly well-oiled
machine and we made 24 episodes of Nash
Bridges over the course of that 10
months and so I think what I took away
from it was like being part of a piece
of machinery like that that was running
at peak performance understanding that
you know that it was it was fiercely
scheduled immaculately well run and you
would you basically went into the
writers room we had three weeks to pitch
story ideas for what we're gonna be in
that season then those story ideas were
approved and then every six days one of
those episodes went up on the board and
then you were off to out like everything
was just like incredibly well-run and so
the idea of like oh this is something
that I had long sort of imagined in my
in my brain to be you know a creative
process which of course it was was also
there is an assembly line here there is
they call this this business that we're
all in an industry for a reason and as
yucky as that sound sometimes if you're
gonna do it well you sometimes have to
say like there there is a product that
is coming off the line and this is
what's happening to it as it goes down
the line and if you're a worker on that
line which I wasn't Nash Bridges if the
product looks flawed you're supposed to
pull on the thing and the line stops and
all these things and so I did like I did
have that moment where neo sees the
matrix you know where you're like which
is sort of like an unglamorous way of
being like oh it's all zeros and ones
it's all green zeros and ones but like I
think going through Nash Bridges that
that part of like oh okay
there's a management side to to it and I
wanted to look at it purely from a
creative standpoint of we're just
telling stories man but but that was
that was critical experience to have
moving forwards and and like the Nash
Bridges staff was kind of crazily
high-powered like I don't think anybody
gives Nash business
credit for having let's do it let's
[ __ ] do it
Carlton Cuse Glen Mazzara Sean Ryan John
worth Pam VC they say and yourself like
that's a [ __ ] all-star roster of
heavy hitters yeah a lot of I actually
Sean left the year before I came on and
I was ostensibly Sean's replacement
although he'd been on now II think for
like three years because he had written
a spec because he was worried that
nobody would take him seriously as a
like a prestige drama writer coming off
of Nash Bridges so he wrote this very
gritty crime story a crime pilot called
I think like the farm or it might have
been called rampart and he used it as a
writing sample and that was the pilot of
the shield
they literally shot it just like that so
he you know and and at that time for
those of you who haven't seen the shield
it's incredible but it everything that
we know of in terms of what FX has
become and I I love effects I think it
they have incredible they make
incredible TV the shield was what
started all that I'm Sean all right so
Watchmen the last time I saw you and
it's not a name drop because he's here
we're friends we're friends there's that
too but the last time I saw you you were
deciding whether or not to do Watchmen
you were like hey listen so they brought
this thing to me I've said no a couple
of times I I'm I I don't know do you
think I should do it and I said no and
then you said well that's not the right
answer and I said well okay somebody's
gonna do it I feel like you at least
know where all the bombs are hidden
you'll know how to navigate through that
particular minefield
what were the deciding factors and you
ultimately saying yeah it's a it's a
good question and I want to give you as
honest of an answer as I can without the
benefit of hindsight
and I and I think that the answer is
that is is a romantic answer I was
thinking with my heart and not my head
and I think that if anyone in this room
is in love or has ever been in love you
didn't decide to be with that person you
just saw them and you were like I'm
gonna do that and then as you go not do
that you're going to ask for consent to
potentially do that Yeah right I'm
feeling these feelings and then if you
go on a first date with that person and
they you know there are all these
reasons you that they you start to have
a conversation and you're like oh we're
different religions or they they they're
a vegan and I'm a carnivore and these
things are never going to work and these
should be red flags but I'm still
falling deeper and deeper and deeper
into this relationship and I really want
to be with this person here I go it was
more that process which is the first two
times that I was asked about Watchmen
one of them was before the leftover
started and the other one I was deep in
process on leftovers and both times I
was very much of the mind of leave
Watchmen alone like of all the things to
leave alone that thing should it should
just be left alone and this is not to
take anything away from Zak's movie but
it had just come out in 2009 and so like
in 2011 was the first time they came to
me and they were like Watchmen and I was
like that you just made the movie and
then again I think in like 2013 a couple
years later and by then I was just like
hey I'm doing leftovers I can't do two
things at the same time thanks for
asking fYI leave it alone and then and
then a couple years later and I and I
think like 2016 was the third time they
came to me and what there were there was
a confluence of events one of which was
that I was finished with the leftovers
and so when I when I when I finished
with the project my antenna goes up
and it starts receiving right now my
antenna is down so like I I literally
couldn't get inspired by anything
because my antenna is down I'll just
know what if it's like a tingling that's
out of my head when it goes up and so
and the other thing that was happening
was and I'm just like I completely and
totally acknowledge that I'm I'm virtue
signaling right now but it is what was
happening was that like every white male
liberal in Los Angeles we were all
talking about how much Tonya has two
coats we were reading it's like Oh have
you read between the world and me twice
you know
not only have I read between the world
and me but I you know but I've read all
of his essays in the Atlantic so I was
like oh I've got a I've got to read
these things and so I started because I
felt like it was the thing that I had to
do because I was a progressive and I
cared about racial inequality but then
when I read Tana I see Coates
I got deeply and profoundly affected
like it was like a van it was it was
like religion and I fell in very very
deep and in the in the case for
reparations which was this essay that he
wrote in the Atlantic and if you haven't
read it you should incredibly he's of
writing and an important piece of
American history I completely and
totally again to kind of go to the you
know the red pill you know sort of
matrix analogy like I felt like I just
saw the world in an entirely different
way after that and in that piece in case
of reparations he talked about the Tulsa
massacre of 1921 and the destruction of
black Wall Street and I was like what's
that I never heard of it and I consider
myself to be a fairly well educated
person who cares about this stuff and I
was like I'm gonna go to a Wikipedia
page and the more I read about it the
more I was amazed at the fact that a
that this had happened and B that I
didn't know that it had happened
and so it felt like the initial crime of
the destruction of of Tulsa in 1921 and
and what was happening there was
horrific but even more horrific was the
idea that had been kind of erased and I
was like I feel compelled to tell
everyone that I know about this thing
that happened
and I would start saying to people just
in you know dinner conversations or hey
have you ever heard about black Wall
Street and people would be like no and
then I would start talking and I would
see their eyes kind of glaze over
not because they were bored but because
I think it was too much to take in and I
was like I've got to find a way to to
like Trojan horse this story into
something where people have to see it
that they I wouldn't buy a ticket for
Thoth for a movie called Tulsa 21 in the
same way that I probably wouldn't have
seen Chernobyl cuz it's like you know I
don't I don't need two Nobel in my life
everyone around you start saying you
have to see Chernobyl and then you
decide whether or not you're gonna do it
but I think a lot of people who even
writers in this room or who acknowledge
that Chernobyl is probably great you
have to move through that membrane uh
this is going to be unpleasant me
watching what happens in Chernobyl
knowing what happens is gonna be
unpleasant so I was trying to figure out
how do I and should I even tell the
story this isn't my story to tell Who am
I like Who am I to tell this then they
offered me Watchmen for the third time
and I literally said in that call this
isn't my story to tell this is Alan Alan
Moore doesn't want me to tell this story
and when I said those words I was like
oh it's the same thing with Tulsa 21
maybe I should just tell both stories
I'm not supposed to tell at the same
time and like it's like double hubris
and then they've literally said you
could do anything that you wanted with
it and I said let's test what the
confines of that mean and and then and
and the rest is history
okay which one
I remember when when episode one
premiered and watching the reaction
online how many people thought it was
fiction all of it
like but that never happened I'd have
known if that happened how aware were
you of that conversation as it began to
unfold the sense that there's an
audience for this that doesn't know that
this is fact I got the sense you know as
soon as we as soon as I started pitching
it and and said look this is not this is
the cornerstone of the season and at the
time that I was pitching in to HBO sorry
guys I'm gonna spoil stuff about
Watchmen if you haven't seen it yet but
I'll try to kind of talk around it a
little bit so that if you haven't
watched it have interested in watching
it thorough but be still
still some discovery but I'm gonna spoil
the [ __ ] out of it he's gonna be the
nice one but but when we went in and
pitched to HBO for the very first time
and said Tulsa that this thing happened
and and and in that very meeting the
executives were sort of like wait are we
in the pitch right now or is this a
thing that actually happened I was like
that is a thing that actually happened
but and were and were also in the pitch
and and so in that moment I realized
that that was that was ground zero for
what the how the audience was going to
react and had I not read the the Coates
piece that's how I would have react
reacted and and Watchmen is a piece of
popular fiction that deals with real
world history and also alt history and
so there's a purposeful blurring of oh
wait a minute that's real and so then
the question is how are people gonna
feel when they find out that that what
happened in in Tulsa in 1921 was real
and the answer is it depends on the
color of your skin and the reaction that
was kind of new to me with the exception
of Regina and I'll talk about that in a
second was that sort of like
white people for the most part we're
gonna have this is it's a broad
generalization but for the most part
we're gonna be like I'm embarrassed that
I didn't know what this was
that's the word that they would use or I
even I'm ashamed and I felt both those
things but at the same time it sort of
it's a failure of the way that we were
educated so we
can't take complete and total blame and
that people of color said yeah you know
and by the way while we're on the
subject it tells the 21 you want to talk
about rosewood like you know this is
just one of 80 things that we know about
that you don't know about and so that
that part of the conversation I wasn't
ready for until Regina read the script
and because she was the first person of
color really who I talked to about
here's you know here's what were here's
what we're going where we're going and
what we're doing with this by that time
the writers room was sort of up and
running but when I was interviewing
writers none of them when I when I
talked about Tulsa 21 they just nodded
but nobody said to me you know what was
the same candor as Regina did we we have
been talking a lot as a culture both as
viewers of material and writers who make
material about who gets to tell what
story and without judgment at all what
made you think that you were the person
to tell this story as ridiculous as I
know this sounds the answer your
question is I'm not you know I'm not the
person to tell this story I'm still not
and I don't think that there's any part
of me we've got one episode of the show
left to air but after eight episodes
have aired and I feel like I've more or
less gotten the benefit of the doubt in
terms of understanding all along that
the that to approach this in the wrong
way would have been harmful but the
reality is is that I view myself more as
a curator than as the person who's
telling this story so as a cure if you
think about a museum you walk into a
room and there's art and sculpture or
whatever hanging on the wall and the
curator is not the person who made that
art but they're the ones who decided
that this was gonna be the the art that
was in this room and where they're gonna
place it and so I brought together a
writers room of people whose story it
was and who could tell that story
authentically
and in all honesty my initial ma I sort
of had this very kind of you know
benetton vision in my head of this is
gonna be an incredibly diverse and
inclusive writers room and I'm just
gonna sit there and I'm gonna listen and
I'm gonna be informed and educated but
really what I was thinking is and then
once everyone's done talking I'm gonna
run the show and what happened was I was
very quickly sort of like overwhelmed by
the fact that if Watchmen was going to
be any good I really did have to listen
and I really did have to cede power and
I really did have to cede voice and so
the watchmen that everyone has been
watching is not just a collaboration but
I think I got out of the way a lot and I
can identify the places and times when I
got out of the way because that's when
people of color say I feel real
authenticity there's no way that I can
I could have created that authenticity
it only exists there because there were
five black writers in the writers room I
mean I I can't speak to what it was like
inside the writers room but I think we
all as writers have been wrestling with
this question for a while and to me and
it always come down to are you willing
to do the work you know cuz we're
writers our job is to pretend to be
other things that were not you know for
men to be able to write women for women
to be able to write men for people to be
able to write aliens for elves and
[ __ ] gnomes all of that [ __ ] we have
to be able to pretend to do this job and
the good writers do the work to get that
sense of specificity and the thing that
that I respond to and some members of my
community do and those are both black
and nerds and black nerds is that it
feels like the work was done you know
and the problem that that people of I
guess marginalized communities often
have is that the work doesn't get done
you know and so you get Emma Stone as a
half Polynesian or whatever that was so
no you didn't do the work and Watchmen
feels like the work got done i i i
really appreciate you saying that and i
feel like i part of part of it is never
feeling like the work is done
I think once you arrive at and I've
always felt this way about writing but
but I think it is applicable to what
you're talking about now which is that
you don't stop like you never get to the
point where you're like nailed it you
know I have achieved balance like you
know again because we just keep you know
the matrix just as applicable to
everything but this sort of idea of like
uh you know I'm the one like is like it
just never happens and so if you stop
and say got it then then then I think
you're you're all is lost you're [ __ ]
but is if you keep thinking I I'm
reaching for it or I haven't got it yet
you just never stopped that's maybe the
only way that that you can achieve it
and I think that there's no shortage of
great intention but great intention is
not an excuse for for [ __ ] up you
have to go one step beyond great
intention which is to feel genuinely
uncomfortable and I'll say I feel
uncomfortable now that's okay
like if a if a white person is talking
about race in America it's okay to feel
uncomfortable like when you start
feeling super comfortable you're in
trouble because like it's an
uncomfortable topic and you kind of
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about and so I'm I'm entirely
comfortable saying that I know a lot
more now than I did two years ago when I
started this journey but I still don't
know what I'm talking about and and and
that's that that has to be okay mm-hmm
speaking of this room how what was your
first steps and putting it together like
how did how did you assemble your United
Colors of Benetton writing staff so the
the the show was just okayed for a pilot
and I like I like to make pilots and
that's the only way that I've ever done
it it's an imperfect system but it is
survived through the ages for a reason
and so lost was a pilot the leftovers as
a pilot and I want to watch them to be a
pilot I this is not anything against
shows that are picked up straight to
series but I love the idea of just sort
of like focusing all of your energies on
the first one and if you can't get one
right then there shouldn't be anymore
at the same time we couldn't write a
pilot for this season of Watchmen unless
we knew what the finale was and so I was
like I need like 12 weeks in a writers
room with a lot of people before I can
even figure out what the pilots gonna be
and we should sort of figure out what
the pilots gonna be together and HBO
said cool you go and do that go assemble
your room so the so you know it's like a
heist movie to some to you know to some
degree where it's like you need someone
to blow up in the safe and you know you
got to get Don Cheadle just because he's
there he was unavailable yeah but um so
the the first thing that you do is you
is you know like who have I worked with
before that would be good in this room
and let's figure out who those people
are and then you all build the rest of
the room around them so Jeff Jensen was
the first person that I hired and the
first person that I talked to about
Watchmen formally because he was the
only person on earth that I knew and
trusted who had a an even more intense
reverence and to protect the original
Watchmen more than I did and so I think
we needed just a watchman scholar in the
room who anytime I was going to a berate
too much from the Canon would would say
you cannot do that and knew me well
enough to not be afraid to say you
cannot do that and then and then I hired
Tom spazzy Ally Nick Q's and Lela byock
all of whom Tom helped me run the
leftovers and Nick and Lila were both
writers on the leftovers and I just had
a shorthand with them I felt that they
were both fantastic writers and then I
was like okay so there are now four
white dudes on the staff just going
through that phase so no more white
dudes like and that's not that that's
it's probably against the law for me to
say that because there's a weird
affirmative
action laws or whatever but I was trying
to I was trying so I said now as I
basically move out into the world I'm
talking to agents as like I want writers
of color and women and but more
importantly for where I'm going now I've
got two writers that's Jeff and I who
have real intimate familiarity with
Watchmen and Leela and Tom and Nick not
so much Nick a little bit Tom and Leela
almost nothing so for the remainder of
the room and ultimately I want to have
about 12 people in the room it should be
half people who have familiarity with
Watchmen half people who have no
familiarity with Watchmen
because what I'm solving for is a season
of television where people who love
Watchmen will be a will will will dig it
and people who don't have any
familiarity with Watchmen can understand
it and knowing the way that I tell
stories my the way that I say to my goal
was I want two people watching the pilot
one of whom knows Watchmen chapter
averse the other knows nothing about it
at the end of the pilot the one who
knows nothing about it turns to the one
who knows everything about it and says
what the [ __ ] just happened and the one
who knows everything about it goes I do
not know and so we're all in it together
moving forwards that was my wife and I
watching the pilot yeah it's like what's
with the squids I think yeah but I have
some ideas so so I got sent stacks and
stacks of scripts and so for me I want
to I want to read I want to read writing
and and then take the meeting and so I
got samples from playwrights and from
veteran TV writers and from people who
had lots of experience and people who
had relatively no experience and I just
read them and for me I know sort of
within like seven or eight pages of your
sample whether or not it's arbitrary as
to whether or not you're a good writer
almost every sample that I read was
written by good writers professional
writers but whether or not they had what
I thought was the sensibility and the
voice for Watchmen and again it was like
broad range of different samples some of
them were John was ample some of them
were cop shows it didn't really matter
what it was it was just all about
whether or not I had you know over time
it's the Malcolm Gladwell sort of 10,000
hour rule where I've just read enough
scripts to kind of know oh I'm gonna get
along with this person pretty well and
by time I sit in a room with them so the
next step is basically now I have
meetings and half of the people that I
have meetings with are gonna end up in
the room and the other half are so it's
it's it's really like just it's just a
50/50 shot and if we can hang out and
chat for like 45 minutes we're good in
the case of Watchmen I also had the
opportunity to pitch the show to these
writers so some of them came in and like
I said they knew I'd the one thing that
I didn't know is what they knew about
Watchmen when when I solicited the
meeting and and I would assume that most
of you guys in this room if I read your
sample and I call your agent or I call
you and say like hey come in at 11
o'clock on Monday you're gonna do a
little bit of homework on Watchmen a
couple of the writers who I interviewed
were like yeah you know I know that I'm
meeting on Watchmen but I gotta be
honest with you like I read like four
pages the comic book and I just have
like I it is you know it just wasn't my
thing and get the trap door remote
control well I hired one of them one of
them who said that it wasn't their thing
because I was basically like I'm gonna
make it your thing and and but then so
there'd be a brief conversation about
Watchmen what did you think of it what
do you think it is some people have just
seen Zach's movie and kind of done the
Wikipedia dive others had had read it
five or six years earlier etc so phase
one of the meeting is let's talk about
Watchmen and what what are your feelings
about Watchmen phase two of the meeting
is I'm gonna pitch you the show like so
by that time I knew a lot I knew that
you know Tulsa 21 as Krypton will Reeves
is gonna grow up he's going to become
the first masked costumed adventurer he
has to hide his race
his mask because he's living in a very
lent time of and working alongside
racist cops and and then the story writ
large is going to begin in 2019 Tulsa
and it's a legacy story between he and
his granddaughter who didn't really even
know that he existed and it's it's
they're basically gonna connect and I
would talk about skip gates and finding
your roots which I was obsessed with and
there was this episode that he did with
Questlove that was like sort of the
jumping-off point for all this so I
would talk about all that stuff so I
would pitch for like ten minutes and see
how it played and and the people who
were basically like that's the greatest
thing that I've ever heard
signed me up I did not hire and the
people who are like there's some really
good stuff in there but I have questions
and concerns and I hired and that that's
an oversimplification but also mostly
entirely accurate because I think one of
the big challenges for me at this point
on 46 this is my third show is finding
people who will tell me I'm an idiot
because I'm an idiot like it doesn't
mean that I'm not only an idiot like I
have to acknowledge that I'm talented
enough to have gotten here and I do have
good ideas but I also have really bad
ideas the problem is I can't tell the
difference I can't tell the difference
between the good ideas and the bad ideas
so I need other and I need other people
to tell me and if I get to the point
where the show is on the air and the
critics tell me then I didn't hire a
good room you know like I shouldn't get
to this rep shouldn't have this
revelatory point of why am i fifty
percent on Rotten Tomatoes when I
thought that I was [ __ ] spitting out
good ideas the entire time turns out
that half of them were really bad and so
that that's that's kind of and so we
ended up with with that original gang
that I told you about
and then crystal Henry who she was a
Chicago cop for seven years her mom was
a cop mom may still be a cop so
matriarchal cop family fell
like that would be incredibly useful to
have that perspective in the room she
was a black woman cop in Chicago who was
subjected to incredible racism both from
the people that she was policing and her
fellow officers so incredible and also
an incredible writer two young
playwrights Stacy OS acre for and Clair
Keisha both of whom had fairly limited
writers writers room experience Clair
had been on the Oh a and Stacy had
worked on the show called happy but they
hadn't like they hadn't been
institutionalized by the writing system
long enough to feel like there were
rules and that was super exciting so
they were green but not so green that
they needed on-the-job training
this guy court jefferson who was a
writer on the good place and also
succession and also wrote this episode
of master of none that knocked my socks
off
he he's incredible writer this guy
Brandon Jacobs who is a MacArthur Genius
playwright he was there for the first
twelve week period commuting back from
New York where he was teaching Jeanine
neighbors who she had worked on she just
come off of a Marti Noxon show so like a
real incredible character writer and I'm
trying to remember I'm sure that I'm
forgetting someone
Carly Rae was not in the original room
she actually thank you she came in
around the time that we were breaking
episode four and five but she was also a
writer on the leftovers and had done
we've been working on Westworld when we
were originally staffing Watchmen so
wasn't available but she came in she
came in midseason so 12 weeks to break
both the world uh-huh and the pilot
right and then what happens after those
12 weeks you go off and shoot a pilot
then we're at then I write the pilot and
we shoot and they we shot the pilot in
Atlanta so the writers room went down
and then I edited the pilot and then HBO
watch the pilot and they were like we
want to make we want more so reconvened
the room for those writers who were
still available and then with that time
car we had not broken episodes two
three but we knew a lot about we knew a
lot about what they were gonna be and
then we just went hard in the writers
room breaking episodes we got we we were
able to have scripts for two three and
four by time we went into production but
there was a wrinkle and the wrinkle was
that so there's this Jeremy Irons adrian
veidt's storyline on the show and as
conceived in the original Watchmen
there's this thing called tales from the
black freighter which is a comic within
the comic and so almost not every issue
but most issues of watchmen you're
getting another installment of the black
freighter and i was like i want to do
that for TV but with Adrian Veidt and so
every episode of Watchmen you're gonna
get like five minutes of Jeremy Irons
and and no matter how bad the rest of
the show is I figure most people are
gonna be like I'll tune in for that
because he's doing all the things he's
doing all the things and and we had
already shot the pilot and his take on
the character was comedic and you know I
know I I traditionally don't I think
that he has a very wry sense of humor
but I never when we cast Jeremy Irons I
wasn't like okay you're gonna do this
alright
like let's get farting in the courtroom
so like so he inspired this whole kind
of like wackadoo notion but we're gonna
have to we had this castle in Wales that
we only had access to for as long as the
weather was good so we had to write all
eight of the Veit scenes including ones
that you haven't seen yet that are gonna
be in the finale on Sunday we had to
write those first before we wrote even
broke episode two so I was like this is
a good thing because we sort of have to
commit to our course of action I'm not
gonna spoil anything for you but I am
gonna say Jeremy Irons story does in
fact coincide with the rest of the story
like it's not just it ties in and so I
was like we'll write this first and that
what that's gonna lock in you know this
entire storyline so it's a little bit
scary but probably probably good to
commit and and so we wrote essentially
like 70 pages of light stuff first went
to Wales shot that
while we were starting to break episodes
2 3 & 4 and so that was writers that was
writers room version 2.0 and then as one
as want to do we got behind on cuts
behind on scripts and this is probably a
flaw in my process but I need to be in
the writers room like and as you know
you've been there and for any of you
guys who've been in the writers room
it's the most it can be wonderful and
fun but most of the time it's like
SuperDuper grueling and there's no
shortcuts you can't I can't say I'm just
gonna leave the writers room for two
days and when I come back in you guys
will have figured it all out we have to
figure it out together that's the only
way to do it and so we took a production
hiatus for four weeks right around
January of last year and we had already
broke we had already had a script for
Episode five and the break on Episode
six but it ended up being really
important for production because episode
six was super ambitious it was almost
like another pilot because it shot an
entirely different style in the rest of
series and other than Regina with you
know with sort of like momentary
appearances it's an entirely new cast
from top to bottom so production needed
to be prepping episode six without
having to shoot Episode five behind it
so during that as a result of taking
that breath we lost cord he had to go
back onto the good place he ended up
coming back in again he wrote the script
for six with me but then disappear then
we lost him and and that's sort of when
Carly you know was full timing and at
that point so it was a little bit more
like a sports analogy where players are
getting injured and there was like a
midseason trade you know so there were
bodies moving in and out of the writers
room until we kind of like crossed the
finish line
gasping for air okay to back up just a
little bit I know it's hard to ask you
to tell me what which came first given
that so much of the show feels a little
bit like the workings of a clock like it
all feels very well machined and
engineered to within an inch of its life
but did Cal as
to Manhattan come first did the origin
of hooded justice come first like what
was the revelation that made all the
other revelations possible hooded
justice came first hands down and and
and hood of Justice hood of Justice
maybe even came before black Wall Street
like those two ideas kind of fell in
with one another where it's like oh
that's his Krypton but the idea I've
been obsessed with hooded justice so in
the original Watchmen in the original
text the Old Testament as we called it
in the writers room and those 12 issues
there's this character hooded justice
who looms very large and very
mysteriously in like the first three
issues of Watchmen he appears in the
actual comic book very briefly and most
significantly he there's a sexual
assault happening between the comedian
and and Sally Jupiter and hooda justice
comes in and and beats the [ __ ] out of
the comedian and in the and because the
comedian is now murdered several decades
later it seems only reasonable to say
like hooded justice might have been
involved in this in some way or else
they wouldn't be showing us this but
more importantly at the end of every
episode of Watchmen there would be these
ancillary materials and in this case
three or four pages of an autobiography
that was written by one of the
characters Hollis Mason who was also in
this group the Minutemen and he he
talked about who to justice a lot and so
my dad who my father I had a very
complicated relationship but the one
place that it was an uncomplicated was
when we were talking about movies and TV
shows and comic books so he gave me
Watchmen the first two issues when I was
13 years old probably inappropriate
content for a thirteen-year-old but he
was sort of it was his way of saying
like you here's a way I can talk to you
like and I was like great let's talk
about this so we talked about her to
justice and and we were like hood of
justice is definitely the one who
murdered the comedian we and and as the
issues went on hood had justice faded
more and more into obscurity and then of
course the ultimate reveal was that he
had nothing to do with the murder but
then Alan Moore made this decision he
revealed the identity of everybody else
in the comic book everybody except for
hooded justice
there was like a mention of the fact
that he might have been this circus
strongman who washed up in Boston Harbor
but who knows like and it was sort of
like wow like so for three decades I've
been sort of and I love unanswered
questions and couldn't solve mystery
couldn't man ambiguity like I'm a big
fan of that I know not everybody is but
I was sort of like why why didn't they
tell us who hooded justice was all of
the Minutemen so like there's like seven
or eight of them they are they're all on
a first-name basis they wear masks but
it's sort of like they call captain
metropolis Nelson and they call a
silhouette Ursula and they call niteowl
Hollis but they don't even know hoodie
just as his name they just refer to him
as HJ he never takes his mask off and I
was like what was this guy hiding and is
he like super disfigured under there or
is there something else going on and
just thinking about it thinking about it
thinking about it and then in this
period that I'm describing to you of
they came back to me watching for the
third time and I was like let's pull the
double hubris the triple hubris is okay
Alan more like you don't want me to
adapt your precious Watchmen and I
worship and adore you I'll tell you what
I'm also gonna reveal who Hood of
Justice was and box on your house and
what and and I have to come up with the
real reason for why he would have hidden
his face and the reason that occurred to
me was that he wasn't hiding his
rhetta's his face he was hiding his race
because his fellow Minutemen never would
have gone into costume adventuring in
the first place if it was a black man's
idea and and in our country is basically
built on the idea of appropriation you
know and and the erasing of an entire
history and culture of people we take
their best ideas as our own and say that
they were our ideas and what you know
the Rolling Stones will basically be
like it's all light in Hopkins but you
know but Lane and Hopkins dies poor and
so that's felt like an American story
me and it felt watchman even though the
original Watchmen wasn't dealing with
race the fact that it wasn't dealing
with race felt like it was dealing with
race and so those three uh that you know
that idea came first and then and then
Cal came a little bit later one of the
things that I took away from Mad Max
fury road not the least of which is how
come everybody's not dead yeah which is
like one of the greatest movies in ever
of the last 20 years easy but is this
sort of narrative feeling that though if
the world is that complex then the story
needs to be relatively simple right like
there's there's but so much wavelength
that a person has that an audience has
to be able to absorb information and
process it and then if the if the world
is gonna be simple then the story can be
complex right cuz that's that those seem
to be the levers that as a storyteller
you can pull and I was struck especially
by the pilot even the first couple of
episodes is that for as detailed as the
world is the story is relatively simple
of watchmen it's there's it's a murder
mystery right like the plot isn't
overwhelmingly Byzantine how did you go
about sort of modulating the dispensing
of information like how did you ride
that level in the room how could you
feel that too much was too much I you
know the the the honest and glamorous
answer is you do it by feel and I I'm
constantly gaming the mystery show I
that's what I want to watch that's what
I'm transfixed by that's what sort of
sucks me in I'm sort of like I love
mystery in all its forms and I think
like ultimately that word mystery is the
foundational that that's the meaning of
life to me the meaning of life is it we
can we can we can talk after the after
the Q&A about what what the meaning of
life is fall in love have kids you know
be not be kind to others I'm not taking
anything away from those ideas but the
meaning of life to me is that this ret
the
fact that from the moment that we are
born and have some level of fundamental
cognition to when we die that they that
there is mystery we don't we sometimes
don't know the answers to the most
fundamental questions and story it would
seem as a way that we can process this
this the stress and anxiety of not
knowing what it is we're supposed to do
while we're here or more importantly
what happens when we die or like what
are the rules
there was this some television show that
I was obsessed with when I was a kid
called The Greatest American Hero
and and the premise of the Greatest
American Hero was that there's an alien
spacecraft that either crashes or lands
briefly but at the end of this guy who's
like a high school you know teacher he
gets this suit and when he puts it on he
has superpowers so he can fly around and
he can lift [ __ ] up and I think maybe
even shoot lasers out of his eyes etc
but he loses the instructions for the
suit there's like a manual and he he
loses it so he can't fly particularly
well and the suit is constantly
malfunctioning and I was like that suit
is life like you know like we we just
don't we just don't have the manual we
don't have the instructions and so I'm
fascinated by mystery in all its forms
and so for for for Watchmen the the
mundane mystery is who killed Judd
Crawford well I'm not really that
interested in a mystery that's a pretty
boring mystery and the answer is Wil
Reeves and so if I'm just gonna tell you
guys just in episode 2 as soon as Angela
has a conversation he's gonna be like I
did it and she's and she's not
necessarily gonna believe in and there
will be reasons that don't it's like
well he's in a wheelchair how did he do
it etcetera but the more interesting
question is why did he do it
you know what's his motive now we're
getting into the the crux of the matter
and the thing that's really like the
grist of why we tell stories which is
like what drives a person to kill
another person that's more interesting
the original Watchmen it was all about
the whodunit you can't do a whodunit in
2019 on television anymore the internet
is going to just grab it but you know
and within an episode or two they're
going
solve it anyway and so if you're like
look who did it in Episode seven the
Internet's like yeah you know we knew
that so you you you have to engage
yourself and more other and more
fundamental mysteries and so what are
the mysteries that were really driving
us with which were why did will do it
and who is will you know who is Angela
what is Angela's relationship to will
why didn't she know that she had a
grandfather
why does she why are the cops wearing
masks why are squids falling from the
sky what you know is dr. Manhattan ever
gonna return from Mars is he even on
Mars what the [ __ ] is going on with
Jeremy Irons you know like you know
those are the mysteries that I've felt
we're gonna be the engine of the
storytelling because they were the ones
that tickled me and I think that you
know when ryan Johnson says knives out
is a whodunit
I was basically like I didn't even need
to see knives out to know this is not
gonna be a whodunit we're at the end of
the movie you know Daniel Craig sits
down and tells me who did it and why
Rian Johnson is better than that and lo
and behold that's not what the movie is
I'm not gonna spoil anything you should
see it it's excellent but but it's sort
of like where we're post whodunit now
we're in the you know it there's a
postmodern era in art we are post we are
in the post mystery phase of
storytelling because the hive mind the
internet changed the game entirely has
has become so sophisticated that it was
really interesting to me to say like can
I still still tell a story on a weekly
basis that has the capacity to surprise
people is it pop is it still even
possible we could do it on lost but it's
like Westworld which i found to be an
incredibly sophisticated and
well-designed drama the internet was
like after two episodes got it you know
and so I was like okay I I I don't want
to fool the audience because if you have
a good twist or a good surprise you have
to set it up some people are gonna get
it but can in the only way to distract
them from what you're hiding is to hide
those things in plain sight and one of
the original
one of the things about the original
Watchmen that so captivated me was month
that it shocked me that it surprised me
there's a moment in in the original
Washington I'll never forget it
where Rorschach whose face is obscured
for six issues five issues and you don't
know what he looks like
you know you see the bottom half of his
face but you're like I have no idea
who's under that mask
the cops he gets set up by five it turns
out Veidt and and he jumps out of a
window and he lands on the ground he
can't get up in the cops around him and
they pull his mask off and he's this
redheaded guy who's basically been
walking through the previous four issues
holding up a sign that says the end is
nigh like as a vagabond like looks like
a homeless dude and when I saw his face
and recognized him and realized that I'd
been looking at him for the for the
previous two months that I've been
reading Watchmen but I completely
ignored him and never even I was like I
couldn't breathe and I was like if I can
do if I can still do that trick I can
you know you know the David Blaine is
full of [ __ ] he doesn't do magic but but
he can make people gasp like that's what
I was shooting for that's that's that's
good mystery is it easier to do that
week by week or better question do you
find yourself do you think you're the
kind of writer who would write a show
that drops all at once does does your
affinity for mystery require the weekly
viewing right now yes but I am fast
I am fascinated and doing things that I
haven't done before because that forces
me to do new things and so and I do
binge shows as much as I you know I I
sit on my soapbox or stand on my soapbox
or whatever one does on the soapbox and
and and I'm not a huge fan of binging
but I do it and the reason that I do it
is because if you eat one potato chip
you're gonna eat the entire can of
potato chips up until seven or eight
years ago when some genius coined the
phrase binge as it related to television
viewing maybe it was a decade ago now
up until that point no one ever used
that word to describe an activity that
they were proud of you know if you if
you binge something you felt shame and
guilty and like you know like it was
like Meredith baxter-birney and that you
know where she goes into the aisle and
she's eating all those Oreos and that
made-for-tv movie when we were kids like
you know and and so I'm like binging is
bad and because you're relying on my
level of self-control and in fact the
algorithm is like the next episode will
start in five four it's exactly enough
seconds that in which I can't reach for
the remote or like you know my ability
of like subconscious like well okay you
know like who's gonna turn it off at
that point and so but at the same time
we have there's only so many hours of
the day and one has so much stamina and
so you can't you know you can't do it
all in one shot a lot of the time and so
what you end up doing is you end up
breaking up episodes says like Chernobyl
is five hours long or five episodes long
I don't know what the exact breakdown is
timewise and and so but they're episodes
they are episodes and designed as such
and should be viewed as such and so the
idea of like you should take a mandatory
timeout you know like now if I were
working in Netflix I'd say like we
should program the algorithm to say you
don't get the next episode of stranger
things until like five hours have passed
and then I'd be fired
you know because because they're you
know because there are no you know
because you want to get the big can of
Pringles and and and so I I am
interested in in in creating a show that
would be all in one sitting but I also
like making episodes of television that
have specific beginning middles and ends
in and of themselves and identities but
most importantly I love the idea of the
water cooler and I think that the idea
of no matter how good stranger things is
and I love stranger things it's it's
like we're all watching it at different
times we're all in different places in
the book no one you know there's no way
to sort of synchronize your stranger
things viewing and when you do in
episodic television show
mr. robot is doing it right now so I'm
watching mr. robot as a mr. robot fan
and I know that on Sunday night or
Monday morning that's when I can go on
the internet and see the think pieces
about mr. robot and everyone is in the
same place in the book as I am and that
creates a level of community that I
really appreciate and and I it may still
sound a little bit old-fashioned but
that's what I'm I think went on best at
and so for the for the foreseeable
future that's where I'm most comfortable
because that's the way that I that's the
way that I think stories are best
ingested I remember reading very early
on in the watchman release some press
that you did some interviews you did and
and you in no way made it seem as if you
were interested in doing more watchman
quotes were something like no this
listen I set out to tell these nine
episodes and I think I'm done and then
at the end of episode 8 it said season
finale and not series finale where do
you now stand on doing more Watchmen uh
my position has not changed so and when
I when I first went into to HBO and
pitched them the show I said just so you
know the original Watchmen has a
beginning middle and end and it didn't
you know like there were certainly from
a certain perspective dangling
storylines that might have been
interesting to pursue dr. Manhattan says
he's going to go off and create life huh
what does that mean I'd like to see what
that is Laurie and Dan now under assumed
identities she says I'd like to get some
guns and start wearing leather and be a
little bit more like my dad than my mom
I'm not done being a vigilante I'm like
hi wouldn't mind seeing some of that
Adrian Veidt what happens after you've
saved the world what's your second act
going to be I wouldn't mind seeing some
of that but at the same time and the and
the story ends on kind of an epic
cliffhanger through a certain prism
which is that Rorschach who finds out
about this massive conspiracy to save
the world that results in the death of
three million people
he sent but before he went off to
confront the murderer he sent his
journal to
you know this the new frontiersman which
is kind of like the Infowars of its day
and and and the original Watchmen ends
with this this copywriter taking that
journal off of the crank pile and and
saying hey should we publish this or
should I even read it and his boss says
I leave it entirely in your hands so
that's a cliffhanger right because it's
sort of like wow everything that Adrian
Veidt just did could be undone and at
the same time it also felt like a
perfect ending inception it's only a
perfect ending because the top is still
spinning when the credits start to roll
like that's what makes it a perfect
ending it's also ambiguous like we're
supposed to wrestle with whether or not
it was all happening in Cobbs head so
that that's that but it's still a great
ending when I pitched this season of
Watchmen to HBO I told them what the
ending was it's the same ending that we
basically shot and you will see on
Sunday night and in it and to me it
feels very much like an ending does that
mean that there can't be any more
Watchmen absolutely not I mean this
season existed so in in the wake of that
perfect ending so like I think Fargo
season 1 had a perfect ending I also
think Fargo 2 had to see a perfect
ending and Fargo 3 had a perfect ending
and I can't wait to see Fargo season 4
and all of those shows are called Fargo
and there's some overlap in terms of
that it's all happening in the same
world you know Keith Carradine was it
was Patrick Wilson in the second season
so there's a bit of a family story true
detective is a much more self-contained
anthology but it doesn't mean that you
know McConaughey and Woody couldn't come
busting into any future season a true
detective they all seem to be happening
in the same world but seasonally every
every one of them has an ending and big
little lies season 1 that last I checked
won an Emmy you know for limited series
and yet there's a [ __ ] season two
that that just got nominated for a
Golden Globe in drama series so you can
call it whatever the hell you want a
series or a season but all that matters
is is there going to be any more
Watchmen and to that I would say
yes there probably is going to be more
Watchmen at some point in the future but
I have not had an idea worthy of saying
Eureka here season two we put it all on
the page we put it all in the field
every story that we wanted to tell we
told liked and it and and again my idea
of what a satisfying ending is turns out
to be somewhat different than the
general public's you know that's caveat
you know like you were warned you should
have known that going in like you know
if you go in and eating McDonald's the
sodium content is going to be high they
they when they sew your Big Mac they
don't shouldn't say to you like just you
know there's a lot of sodium in that you
you watched my show you guys know what I
do you know the kind of food that I make
like you don't get to [ __ ] and complain
about how ambiguous the ending is I just
like that's the way it's gonna work so
that's that's kind of where where I am
and but at the same time if someone else
to me if someone watches this season of
Watchmen and they get the idea whoever
they are maybe it's someone in this room
says I I think I know what another
season of Watchmen is and then they made
that season I would be so psyched to
watch it because I got to do ace I got
to do a season of Watchmen and that's a
dream come true for me in the same way
that I got to do a Star Trek movie you
know and these things these stories are
myths they don't belong to anyone that's
it someone is gonna come along and do
another version of loss that's going to
happen I'm not going to be involved
that's cool I'm cool with that that's
part of being a human is we get to grab
the baton from someone else and say
here's my spin on this like I've got
something new to do and I love the
x-files and if it weren't for the
x-files I wouldn't be sitting here
blabbering on right now but there's a
part of me that's like I've seen Chris
Carter's version of the x-files
I don't need Chris Carter to make any
more x-files now I want to see someone
else do it
like what was the x-files to them like
that's the cool thing about art is
people are riffing on on
on everybody else's ideas and when you
when you step out of the America and you
go and you travel around the world you
start to realize that cities are built
on top of cities are built on top of
cities are built on top of cities and
one of the cities had to be destroyed
and decay you know for the next city to
be built and our cities are stories so
I've built my city on knocking it down
just like dr. Manhattan knocks down his
sand castles on Mars or his doppelganger
does and now someone else now there's a
tabula rasa for someone else to come
along I have a sheet more questions but
that feels like the best answer to go
out on if you guys have any questions
now is the time there's a mic that's
gonna be rotating around by all means
pepper him with [ __ ] that I didn't
pepper as their mic hi could you talk a
little bit about your world building and
pitching it in the room for someone
who's not as established to come in and
you're going from 1921 to a future world
like what would your tips be to really
sort of not confuse people i I think
that the short answer that question and
again this is just my perspective is to
is to limit your world building you
should do all the work but don't show
all the work so when you're actually
pitching it to someone else you have to
say I could talk about this for half an
hour I'm gonna talk to you about it for
five minutes and then your goal is to
create a conversation the longer you're
talking in a pitch without someone else
talking the more you are failing
so even when I pitch this season of
Watchmen I limited my my talking to like
under 20 minutes sort of like there's a
reason that TED Talks are limited to
like 18 minutes or whatever it as they
are because that's when people's
attention starts to kind of waver or
more importantly they want to start to
engage and so know your world know the
complexity of your world but but but
give the simplest presentation the more
your it is again to go back to the first
date a pitch is a first date and so when
you're just
eating someone for the first time I
don't go like hello my name is Damon I
have an STD like you know I don't but
like don't say that but yeah but it but
it's sort of like you know save that for
like the you know the third date before
you're actually gonna have sex with
someone like when it's the responsible
time to tell it like you know it's not
the first thing that you should you
should basically say and so you you are
wooing someone when you are pitching to
them and you want to sort of create
they're also looking to see not what the
words coming out of your mouth are but
how you feel about those words and so I
think a lot of times when people talk
about world-building it feels very
didactic and informational and almost
like reading an instruction manual but
what people are people are gonna get
infected by I've been in many situations
where people are like I don't really
understand what you were saying but you
seem so into it [ __ ] it you know take a
shot go you know take a running jump at
this and this was happening before I had
established myself in any position of
being trusted and so if you love the
world that you've built don't be afraid
to let it show your true colors I'm
gonna give the mic to this gentleman in
the front row because Martin thank you
my name is sage um I really not a writer
per se and the reason why I'm sitting in
this chair and I don't I'm not a
binge-watch her either but I watched
Watchmen and I'm truth me so the first
episode [ __ ] me up and Bravo for that
and I thought you're black because your
name is Damon
go figure he still gets to come to the
barbecue stuff well you know he's from
Teaneck New Jersey so I'll give him that
one of the things about the show which I
found interesting is my emotional
reaction as an african-american and and
this said that I had several emotional
reactions throughout watching this this
series and I don't really know which
episode I maybe six or whatever but I'm
one question I had because I thought I'm
think maybe I missed something the
hooded justice you know you have this
hero louis gossett characters you know
whatever but what I didn't get was he go
from his younger character being married
with a child loving the family and then
I flashed to him [ __ ] this the other
day and what I felt interesting about
what that was because I don't know if I
missed the relationship that brought us
to that point for me personally it kind
of felt me before and not James Baldwin
it was their purpose for that thank you
I aspire to be
Mapplethorpe or James Baldwin and I'd
never heard them mentioned in the same
sentence before so that's that's
interesting the show is in constant
conversation with the Old Testament and
so this is one of those things where if
you have if you have an understanding of
the pre-existing watchman it makes a lot
of sense and if you don't like yourself
it seems incredibly jarring and so in
the Old Testament hooded justice in
captain metropolis were in a sexual
relationship and that was established in
the Canon and mentioned multiple times
and and so we had to short that entire
episode which is telling his backstory
in the past is is short handing and
taking shortcuts for those moments and
so essentially we had to take all of
what you just just described and put it
in subtle looks between the two men
I'd say double entendre in terms of the
way that captain metropolis
was saying I think we have a lot in
common you're hiding beneath a mask what
they were actually talking about is this
sort of kindred spirit of understood
sexuality where you know gay men can
recognize one another and then the other
thing that we talked about almost a
quite exhaustively in the writers room
is this idea of in in 1938 which is when
that's on or early 39 is which is when
that scene a stage the vernacular for
gay or queer or bisexual they don't
exist not in the not in terms of where
either of those characters so all they
have is the sexual desire to be with one
another and so we're actually jumping
ahead like almost two months in time
between that first captain metropolis
coming over and make an issuing the
invitation in June saying no to them
having sex but because we'll has curated
these memory pills for Angela there it
happens one on top of the other so I
think that the criticism is totally
valid and we understood that there'd be
a little bit of but this is one of those
things where it wouldn't be Watchmen if
afterwards you didn't then say did I
miss something here and then but the
good news is is the internet if you just
basically googled gay sex no don't do
that
but if you googled captain metropolis
hooded justice relationship you would
get like a huge Wikipedia entry on
everything that I just said and so a
show should play without having required
reading but you know
thank you for sharing that thank you uh
where we gonna go how about over here
into the wings do you also think about
LGBTQ representation when you're
building the writers room yes of course
and and I don't think that it's my my
place to talk about what the what the
sexuality of any writer in that room is
to suffice to say is there was real
representation in the LGBTQ a community
in that room but it's not the kind of
thing that I was able to ask about in
interviews in his candidate of a way is
like someone is clearly you know in
terms of their gender representing a
very specific thing not just in terms of
the way that they look the way they
behave in an interview same is true of
the color of their skin someone's
sexuality is not necessarily evident and
in the case of a couple of the writers
it wasn't something that they were
comfortable talking with in the writers
room until we'd been working together
for three or four weeks so it turned out
fortunately that that that that we had
that representation but I only knew only
one of them told me in the interview
that he was gay and but but yeah it was
definitely particularly dealing with
this knowing that hood of justice and
captain metropolis was going to be a
part of our storytelling that that was
essential not just wanting to have a lot
of diversity in the writers room in
general but I think that it's it's it's
critically important and and also a
place where considering lost and and the
leftovers really didn't have any gay
characters at all a place where I wanted
to improve about know you yeah hold on
wait for the mic thanks for being here
and and honestly as a watchman affection
Otto thank you for building a sequel to
this that's just worthy of the original
in my honest opinion thank you I
appreciate it
speaking of the original what you have
to work with in terms of the
history that you have to develop because
you're bringing this into 2019 in the
same universe that the original the same
alternate history that the original
takes place you have to build a world
not only where dr. Manhattan with you
know wins the Vietnam War for everyone
which Allen you know wrote us but also a
history of what things look like post
1985 when Ozymandias commits his deed
where did you begin to even like map out
what that history looks like with
President Redford and with with true and
the technology at that you know and how
far it's advanced like the DNA
technology and stuff how did you guys
begin to build off of the foundations
that Allen created to spin this entire
history and universe how did you do that
and where did that start that that work
started in that in that 12-week period
that I was describing earlier where we
were both talking about actual we call
it the iceberg which is the majority of
an iceberg is actually underneath the
waterline you we see the part of the
iceberg that's above the waterline and
that's the show but the iceberg that's
underneath the waterline is all of this
stuff that we're talking about world
building and the audience can feel
whether you know that thing's gonna sink
if there's nothing underneath the the
waterline and so the there were some
clues left in the original Watchmen
particularly Redford in the in the final
pages of the original Watchmen there's a
newspaper article that says our our to
challenge Nixon in 88 and then there's a
joke about a cowboy is a cowboy actor
really going to beat Nixon and then
someone says it's Redford the joke being
that at the time that Watchmen was
written Ronald Reagan who was also a
cowboy actor was the president United
States and so we're like okay what if
Redford won and Nixon is now been
they've abolished term limits so Nixon
has been president he could fourth term
16 years the way that the United States
politics tend to work is a Democrat as
president for one or two terms and then
a Republican two terms and so on and so
forth there's real balance so reference
gonna be President for a long time
and if Radford was president for a long
time what would he do and so on day one
of the writers room I was like this is
your homework all 12 of you 11 others
tell me what Robert Redford did you know
we know that he's gonna pass reparations
because the the Coates writing was the
cornerstone of the season and this idea
of reparations for the victims of Tulsa
and there was all this real-world stuff
that happened in actual Oklahoma where
this is real Johnnie Cochran represented
the families of the Tolson massacre and
sued the the the police in the state of
Oklahoma and won and then it got
overturned by the by the state Supreme
Court and then the United States Supreme
Court refused to hear it we were like
well if Redford was president and he
stacked the United States Supreme Court
with liberals they probably would have
heard it so what would a you know so now
now we're creating a an actual
real-world justification for our redford
actions which were obviously that
world's version of Obamacare which is
like it's a good thing that is affixed
to a well-intentioned president that
somehow has a negative stigmata against
the opponents of it
so Obamacare is a bad thing you know
which which it was and no longer is so
anyway that's how I'm just giving you
one case of example of how we formed
that and then we'd say Adrian Veidt he
just saved the world he has a plan for
utopia do we think that plan is going to
work are people going to accept utopia
or are they going to push back against
it and more importantly if you were to
pass reparations real reparations for
trauma incurred against people of color
what are the racists going to do they're
probably not gonna be like you know what
fair's fair
you know it's time to get rid of my
confederate flag no they're gonna do
something and then and then it was
Rorschach masks and so on and so forth
so we started pitching to each other
what we thought the world was going to
look like in 2019 and you know and when
people would start snapping if an idea
was good and you know and we just rolled
with it I I want to know how deep into
Spielberg's alternate filmography you
guys went
too deep too deep yeah you got a pale
horse then how many other horses yeah
horse he just made yeah exactly he made
pale horse instead of Schindler's List
and then and then never made warhorse
because he was like I've already made a
movie with horse and Otello
tell me tell me you reclaimed kingdom of
the Crystal Skull that it just never
happened okay thank you never had people
didn't make movies about aliens anymore
or interdimensional beans because it
happened in real life it was too
traumatic on the end over there yeah hi
I'm a big fan of your show I really like
your writing um I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit more about your
character building in regards to the
Vietnamese American characters like what
your writers rooms look like kind of
deep diving into that because I know you
really talked about having a scholar in
regards to Tulsa and like what was your
process with Vietnamese Americans
because I noticed like in one episode
early on you had North North Vietnamese
flags and later on it was South
Vietnamese flags and the whole idea
about I guess generational trauma has
passed from lady true on to yeah it's a
great question and I we we did not have
any Asian writers and certainly no
Vietnamese American or Vietnamese
writers in the writers room and
understanding that when lady true was
not that she was an idea that appeared
in the 12-week period she was not one of
the ideas that I brought into the room
the we that we knew that there was going
to be a character who fulfilled that
there was going to be an eccentric
billionaire character who lived in Tulsa
who was sort of the new Adrian Veidt and
that Adrian Veidt himself had been
missing but I think in the original
iteration it was a it was a guy and he
was not Vietnamese and as we began to
talk about the character and also the we
did know that Angela was born and raised
in Vietnam connecting this idea of
Angela knew
to be at the hub of the of the series
the the way that it was gonna be a
sequel and at the same time not a sequel
was that this new character Angela a bar
she'd be in conversation with the Old
Testament
obviously her grandfather is hooded
justice but we needed to connect all of
the Old Testament characters to her and
so it may seem like Adrian Veidt is not
connected to Angela a bar but in fact
this in this previous week episode we
realized that he was through cow her
husband and so I basically I was like if
we can't draw a straight line to Angela
that character can't be in the show and
the same was true of eccentric
trillionaire who eventually became lady
true the reason that we wanted to make
her Vietnamese was we're like we don't
have any Asian representation in the
show and more importantly Vietnam is
looming so large and this idea of
generational trauma and legacy is so
important that it would be really
interesting for that character to be
Viet what Vietnamese American has an
entirely different valence in our show
because Vietnam is a state so anybody
born in Vietnam is inherently just as
American as as someone who was born
there before it wasn't a state but that
whole idea of I spent a lot of time in
Hawaii and when we were making lost and
there's this really interesting thing
that they kind of don't tell white
people who are just vacationing down and
why you have to work there which is sort
of like oh [ __ ] we just like colonized
this place too you know we like this
idea of like Hawaii just voted to be a
state and everybody was down with it
that's not what happened in Hawaii nor
Alaska and so the idea of oh Vietnam
became a United State know it was
colonized and so so that idea of
colonization played into the fundamental
idea of white supremacy that is the big
bad of this season of Watchmen and the
big bad of the world as we know it today
in America and so it was absolutely and
totally essential that when we cast lady
true it was an actor who was Vietnamese
as opposed to Chinese or Japanese or
Korean we
like we need someone who is actually
Vietnamese who can basically when we
[ __ ] up we write something that's
culturally insensitive or something that
she wouldn't say or do someone who was
really steeped in the culture and so
when we were casting for lady true I
wanted to have meetings with the actors
before they even read and when I sat
down with Hong Chow who is Vietnamese
American and started talking with all
this stuff she fulfilled the earlier
criteria that we talked about where she
was wildly unimpressed with me she
didn't trust me she was deeply worried
and concerned that her character was
going to fall into all of the tropes and
I was like you will have a real voice
here in the writing of the show you're
not gonna sit in the writers room but
you get to cry foul any time we turn
left instead of turning right and and
more importantly in some of those
episodes that are set in Vietnam we cast
other actors who were who said that they
could speak Vietnamese and and hung we
would send her their audition tapes and
she'd be like this person is not
speaking Vietnamese they're they're
faking it and so she became a backstop
which she shouldn't have had to do she's
an actor but she almost took on a
produce toriel role to that end all
right we have time for one more question
who really wants it the guy in the Rick
and Morty t-shirt that's thank you for
the great work you've done with existing
IP any more film work that we can expect
from you and can you talk to existing IP
you know comic book stuff versus
original stories I made a movie I
produced wrote and produced a movie
called the hunt I don't know if any of
you guys have heard of it but it was it
was cancelled by the president United
States not making that up it's a it's a
political satire that is actually about
conspiracy theory culture that has gone
kind of nutty and it was all based
around pizza gate I don't know what you
guys know about pizza gate but the
general idea is that is that John
Podesta this is all
John Podesta's phone got hacked and
there were some weird emails that
basically got deconstructed by the
alt-right and the Alex Jones sort of
conspiracy theory community that led
them to the obvious conclusion that
Hillary Clinton is having sex with
children in a dungeon in a pizza
restaurant called comet ping pong in
Washington DC and so that enough people
believe this theory that a guy showed up
with a with a assault weapon and walked
into this pizza restaurant and started
firing off rounds and demanded to
liberate the children there so that
Hillary Clinton wouldn't be able to have
sex with them and of course when they
brought him to the dungeon there was
just like you know sodas and all that
stuff in the storeroom and the guy is
now in jail and so I was like oh my god
like how how do people actually believe
this stuff have we come this far and and
so Nick Q's and I wrote this movie
called the hunt which is basically about
an internet conspiracy theory where
liberal elites are hunting deplorable
for sports because that's why wouldn't
we you know and and and Universal we
shot this movie and I think it turned
out pretty well and it's a Jason Blum
movie so it's political satire along the
lines of get out but it's also Shan rrah
and and so they started you know putting
up billboards Ford and commercials and
then these horrific horrible tragedies
happened in El Paso in Dayton and then
the and so we immediately pulled the
advertising for the hunt because it felt
inappropriate to to show humans hunting
other humans in that week and then The
Hollywood Reporter wrote a story that
was sort of like the original title of
the hunt was called blue state red state
which it never was and and left out all
the things about the movie that were a
satire so it's like if someone were
trying to describe dr. Strangelove like
a thriller you know versus a satire
where it's like there's a character who
gives Nazi salutes it's like it's Peter
Sellers like it's a satire anyway that
article from The Hollywood Reporter went
into the Fox news cycle and you know
Tucker Carlson was talking about it the
president United States
saw the 48 hour news coverage on fox
news because they didn't want to talk
about gun safety they wanted to talk
about the hunt and he tweeted about the
movie and called us racists and I was
like he hasn't even seen Watchmen you
know like the hunt doesn't really deal
with race in any in any specific way
there's a there there are a couple
comments about it but in any political
satire there need to be but and then
Universal canceled the release so I hope
that movie is still gonna see the light
of day there you know I know that they
believe in the movie and they like maybe
the political climate is has has cooled
down enough for them to feel more safe
about releasing it but the reason that I
talked about this is not to plug my
movie but to say like if I'm going to
make movies I kind of don't want to do
pre existing IP anymore like there's a
part of me that that I watch the
mandalorian and I'm like oh my god I'd
love to play in the Star Wars universe
but I shouldn't like there's you know
there there's other people who are more
qualified to do that and he'll probably
mix it up a little bit more than I would
and I'm so scared of messing it up and I
love it so much and etc etc and I'm sort
of like I keep saying that I'm not gonna
do it again and then and then I did
Watchmen but I sort of feel like we're
every time I see an original movie I'm
just so grateful that it exists knives
out is the most recent example of that
it was like Rian Johnson can make any
franchise movie that he wants and he
goes and makes knives out and it's a
gift and so I feel like if I'm gonna
make movies I should probably not do
pre-existing IP
although there's nothing wrong with
pre-existing IP as long as you're not
afraid to subvert it like the best
pre-existing IP movie that I saw last
year was into the spider-verse
and it took a lot of risks and
completely and totally reframed
everything that you we know about the
spider-man myth but it was original and
beautiful like and you know for me the
question that I'm getting asked most
often right now because Watchmen as a
piece of comic book IP is what do you
think about what score says he said you
know about about comic book movies not
being a cinema and what I say is Martin
says he hasn't seen you know the dark
night and he hasn't seen into the
spider-verse if you think if he saw
those two movies he might reevaluate his
position
I just I have one last thing that I want
to say and it's between 2017 and Black
Panther and 2019 and Watchmen I am kind
of enjoying this era where we are Trojan
horsing the black experience to white
nerds who would not normally find
themselves in it you know and the twin
mirrors of those things Black Panther is
about black excellence it's like look
how great it could be and Watchmen feels
to me about black pain and it's a thing
that your average to your point white
audience does not willingly engage in
and so to use Watchmen as a vehicle to
reveal history that has been forgotten
is I think the word is Mitzvah so thank
you for that thank you thanks I
appreciate it
thank all of you for coming out in fact
damon lindelof for sharing his night
with us
[Applause]
[Music]
you